all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are covering the full power
if we want to call it that of Loki the
god of stories now if you're just now
joining us you guys actually picked a
great time because if you click the
video at the end of this you'll
literally be caught up in one video
because this is a very recent Thor story
so the long and short of this is that
we've been introduced to these kind of
otard versions of Loki and Thor exactly
what that means we don't fully
understand the story's just started so
it's still kind of unfold holding but
the long and short of this is that in
the fight between Thor and utgard Thor
that basically Thor using the All Power
kind of the Odin Force basically for his
character that he had exhausted his
energy and in doing so has fallen into
the all sleep now for those of you guys
who aren't familiar and I think most
people are but in case you're not the
all sleep is literally what happens
whenever like Odin had to recharge his
energies and had to rest but it leaves
him incredibly vulnerable and so what
ends up happening here is that as we saw
at the end of the last video Loki as the
newly christened God of stories in all
his might had appeared to Thor and then
it seemingly whisked him away so what
we'll find out is that this is all kind
of taking place within the Dreamscape
but it doesn't change the power that
Loki god of stories has and that's one
of the first things to grasp here is
that Loki over the years in Marvel
Comics his power was confined to like
the real world and he could trick
people's minds and just kind of do these
little mischievous things Loki here is
more or less opting is God and not like
an Asgardian God but like a god of gods
you know like complete and total power
over everything and in fact what he does
here is he kind of meets Thor with just
like these riddles and in fact when Thor
approaches this believing it's one of
Loki's games Loki responds and says like
this is no game Thor but it does have
rules and even Moler cannot break them
my magic has bound you to this place the
Rune R the Rune of Journeys but the rune
is reversed its meaning changed an
unwanted Journey plans disrupted the
Rune of Crisis now we're not explicitly
told as to whether or not Loki changed
the powers of the Rune but if he did
this is also massive because
contextually looking at the history of
the Thor comics for example the end of
Thor disassembled when Thor destroyed
the Run Stones it basically obliterated
any and all beings associated with
Asgard and in fact it even wiped out the
those who sit above in Shadow who are
kind of like these Asgardian equivalents
of their gods upon Gods right basically
what we're believed to be these
immutable indestructible beings so the
runes in and of themselves are
astronomically powerful being able to
come along and just alter them on a whim
I would argue in relation to the
Asgardian Mythos is not that dissimilar
from like changing the fundamental
properties of like an infinity stone
right it's just a crazy level of power
and so Thor refusing to buy into the
sche te of Loki as he perceives it
basically takes off and Loki tells him
like if you do that I would pack a lunch
and Thor just ends up out in the middle
of nowhere right like stars that he's
never seen before he doesn't even know
if he's in his own reality and that's
where things get kind of mindboggling
because Loki is the god of stories Les
we forget this guy has the ability to
turn anything that he can imagine into
reality right anything on any scale it
doesn't matter and so seemingly Thor
could be in a location right now that's
just been kind of created by Loki on a
whim it doesn't actually exist and it
never existed until like just now that's
what we're talking about here right it's
just a crazy level of power and so in
the end Thor does kind of muse about the
idea that tanos right that kind of Ard
Thor that exists out there that he
couldn't necessarily find Thor here but
at the end of the day he asked like
where is he now with no Thunder God to
battle what is he doing to my allies
while I Dole here so that's the thing
that brings him back like yes he could
could remain safe here but if he never
returns back to midgard if he never goes
back to Earth and he never defeats that
Ard Thor he would lay waste to the
entirety of the world because even Thor
with all of his vaunted power now that's
one thing to know about the Thor Comics
at the moment Thor and Loki have both
received a massive boost in their powers
even with all of that power that dwarfs
what the Incredible Hulk is capable of
none of the Avengers could even stand a
chance against Thor right now this guy
was smacked around like a ragd doll by
Ard Thor
right what would he do to the
superheroes what chance could they
possibly have and so he ultimately ends
up returning with Loki simply just
waiting on him there and Loki does kind
of do a little bit of musing here but
this is one of the things to know if you
didn't see our first video before this
whole instance between Loki and Thor
took place at the very end of that story
Loki appeared to Thor and said do you
trust me I need you to trust me right I
need you to know that I am not
necessarily your enemy here but I will
appear that way and I going to test you
in ways that you hadn't considered
before will you put your trust in me and
Thor ultimately said yes hence Landing
us in this situation here which is why
Thor sees this on the surface as another
one of Loki's schemes but as the reader
and even on a much deeper level Thor
knows there's something much bigger
going on here than what it perceives to
be and so where Loki kind of presents
him with a giant meal and all that kind
of stuff and almost playing games with
him the response of Thor is like I'm no
one's prisoner right like I am not
playing this game with you and so Loki's
response is have it your way and he just
teleports away and that's it and just
leaves Thor to his own devices all he
tells him is I've given you the clues
that you need to succeed so again it's a
riddle it's a test and so it's really
cool here because Thor does the only
thing he can think to do he lashes out
right his power just kind of runs ay for
a minute there but at the end of the day
once he calms down he's just like okay
right like what do we do here right he
literally says like thou H has fought a
most courageous battle indeed against a
Garden of Flowers indeed thy rage has
scourged it down to bedrock or bed
Crystal as it may be tell me has it
brought you closer to escape literally
for all the yelling and all the
screaming and all the shouting he's made
no more headro in getting out of this
place so that's one of the things it's
one of the first steps in this test is
can you calm yourself can you be more
than just some raging lumbering Beast
with a hammer in his hand that only ever
knows how to attack
which is kind of a Cornerstone of Thor's
Mythos right like when you're a hammer
everything is a nail and that's kind of
how Loki views him and that's what Loki
is trying to get him to stop operating
as right think Beyond some war god with
a hammer and that will be your first
test unfortunately Thor passes it
momentarily and then immediately fails
and the reason why is because he
literally takes off his helmet and says
okay if this is a reality and I have the
Odin Force Thor Force whatever you want
to call it then what better way to
escape this place place than to quite
literally cut through it and so what he
ends up doing is transforming his helmet
into what's basically yarn Bjorn right
like his battle axe kind of reisens it
and then in turn intends to like cut
through the very fabric of the reality
itself and then Loki immediately
reappears and says no do not do that
right do not do that and when Thor's
kind of like why look's response is I
beg forgiveness brother finding you with
a blade at your own throat I fear the
worst although maybe not the worst
compared to the Fate that awaits you if
you fail so literally Thor was seemingly
going to just end all his living and
believing that he could just kind of be
reborn wake up from this dream that kind
of thing and emerge out in the real
world but when Thor throws his hammer at
Loki Loki just kind of vanishes like
disappears and then reappears right so
again Thor is way out of his League here
way out of his depth in dealing with
like the power of Loki here it's Child's
Play now this is not really a grandiose
display of his abilities Loki has time
and time again teleported out of the
path of Thor's hammer right it's not
really unique it's not really
mind-blowing or anything like that but
what he says here is stupendously
important he says taking my head off
would be too easy Thor you can't just
hack your way through this gordian knot
but if you want some lateral thinking
you have a get out of jail free card in
your own hand are you not King of Asgard
hero of a thousand battles who deserves
Valhalla if not you and once there who
could stop you walking out again do it
Thor cut the thread of fate and fall the
Valkyries will most surely catch you and
Thor's response here is simply just the
ways of death cannot be gained Loki as
you well know there are forces to which
even a God must vow you are correct
however I do have the solution right
here and this is one of those things
where Thor isn't thinking he's not
paying attention what Loki said right
literally are you not the the king of
Asgard hero of a thousand battles who
deserves Valhalla if not you and once
there who could stop you walking out
again literally what he's telling him is
no cage can contain you like there's no
limit to what can hold you and what can
control you all you have to do is start
seeing things that way but again in that
moment Thor just like takes his hammer
and he throws it at the run staff and
destroys the Rune staff and Loki just
kind of looks at it and it's like that's
your grand plan here that's your idea it
should destroy the stone like sure but
destruction is only one side of the coin
of existence the other side is creation
and Loki just recreates the staff again
now that's an important distinction Loki
just created a run Stone out of nowhere
and again if we look at the runestones
as an as guardian concept that's
comparable to Infinity Stones it's
creating an infinity stone out of
nowhere again they're not exact in terms
of power but in relation to the
Asgardian Mythos itself all the
asgardians live and die by whether or
not the runstone exist their destruction
led to the destruction of all things in
relation to Asgard like the entire
dimension of Asgard the asgardians
themselves the whole nine yards right so
again it's crazy Loki has this power and
yet Loki again soly just tells him the
tools are in your hands brother and then
smashes his staff on the ground and
disappears again and that's it and I
guess his kind of own Loki way you have
to start thinking outside the box and
that's when Thor begins to start putting
two and two together right he says a
gordian knot a seemingly complex problem
with a simple answer Loki arrives behind
my back but makes a point of leaving in
front of my face always showing me their
staff of means of travel no trick of
mine will save me I am told which leaves
a trick of the trickster's own a rune
staff that matches theirs a simple
answer and yet is it that simple I
simply bang my Kane on the ground like
Donald Lake and the game is over or am I
simply playing a Fool by putting my
trust in and that's when Loki reemerges
right and he says you thought a
whittling stick would solve my riddle
fool that you are you have failed
thunderer and now you must die and yet
magnanimous as I am I offer you one last
chance to survive my wrath bestow upon
me the Throne of Asgard give to me the
role of all father swear to serve me all
the days of thine mortal life and Loki
the fish God of evil will let you live
and the response that Thor gives here is
really that's it and that's when Thor
figures it out right in that moment
that's when he knows he's right because
he literally says after all the road you
and I have walked together there is one
thing I know in my Maro any Loki who
says they want a throne is a liar now
the reason why Thor draws this
conclusion is that if this was the Loki
in years past he'd be 100% right because
Loki the original God of tricksters was
always scheming to get Thor out of the
equation and to take the Throne of
Asgard for himself but Les we forget
like we covered in our Loki god of
stories video explain that there was the
original God of tricksters he basically
sacrificed his life pulled a few rses to
be reborn as his younger self took over
the body of that child became the Loki
who's in effect the god of stories and
went on the path to become a superhero
but in trying to become a good guy he
cast aside all those Ambitions to kill
Thor and replace him as the god of
Asgard right the ruler of Asgard the new
Odin if you want to call him that he's
no longer that guy and so suddenly
approaching Thor out of nowhere and
saying give me the Throne of Asgard you
know right like bend the knee swear fail
he to me in the end that's when Thor
realizes no like this means that I
solved the riddle right if I had given
into this and if I had said okay that
means he would have failed and in taking
the staff and striking it on the ground
he's woken up from the Odin sleep and he
in turn returns there and that's when he
has the conversation with Loki and Loki
reveals why he's even doing this in the
first place right like after a little
bit of conversation with Thor saying
like I recognize these stars and all
that kind of good stuff he asked him
what was meant by this game Loki and the
response of Loki this is stupendously
important here because he says no game
you had a lesson to learn you learned it
you needed a weapon for what coming and
you have it you were tested and you
passed and he asked like if I failed
what then and the response of Loki is
you'd be dead right starved Bones on an
alien world in a forgotten taunt and
then tonos would wreak havoc across
everything understand this Thor if I
come to you as your enemy it is the
enemy you need and I will not coddle you
and so in effect what he's saying is
this is but the first of many tests of
many trials given my my new role and my
power I cannot solve these problems for
you but what I can do is I can push you
to become better now this is a very very
important thing to understand with
regards to how aling and Marvel are
handling Loki god of stories because as
they solidified in Loki volume 3 right
like The God Who Fell to Earth and the
storyline from Defenders Beyond Loki
officially being the god of stories
means he's arguably equal to the one
above all in power anything that he can
imagine
becomes real but in order to prevent him
from becoming a McGuffin where he just
kind of appears in the midst of any
conflict and just says away with you and
waves his hand and the conflict's over
they have to find a way to structure him
and a way to bring him in that allows
him to still maintain some presence
within the Asgardian stories but at the
same time not make him this just
overwhelming omnipotent force that can
end everything this is it right this is
him appearing to Thor and saying I will
make you great right you are good and
you are capable I will make you better
that's basically what he's doing here
but the other part of this is remember
with the utgard as Guardians that exist
out there Loki Thor so on and so forth
they're basically Elder Gods right Gods
from a time that's long since passed and
their power dwarfs that of Thor and
probably not Loki god of stories but the
point here is that Thor is going to need
to be more than simply just a hammer
hitting nails if he's going to win he's
going to have to learn to think outside
of the box and so in doing that Thor
says indeed the solution to the riddle
of tanos is now Within Reach we will
need allies for what comes next allies
who share the necessary experience
though I fear at least one will not
enjoy seeing Loki at her door if she is
to join us in battle he says I must
speak to the goddess of thunder alone
Thor is going to find storm which is
amazing because remember storm control
RS the weather and she has a massive
power boost as well in Marvel Comics
which is covered in X-Men red and is
part of fall of X so with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you want to get caught up on
Thor make sure you click this video but
if you want to follow along with what's
going on with storm and the X-Men in
Fall of X click this link and it'll take
you to the fall of X playlist the choice
is yours ladies and gents and I will
catch you all later peace